Analytics intro that cover the types of
reporting that we do and and also a
little bit on some some ideas for for
what we're trying to accomplish here.
Is is that a good place to get started or
do you have somewhere else you you'd want
to start?
That's perfect. Let's start there.
Cool.
All right.
So some different types of of reporting
that we execute for our clients.
So the 1st is physician level data,
it's called P, you know,
PLD or you'll hear the acronym.
So this is essentially the the physician
or MPI level activity.
It's shared on a weekly or monthly basis.
At an individual HCP level,
just something you know it's kind of
unique about you know this,
you know the space that we're in of
course in terms of how having to allocate
you know the activity for almost
everything that we do to to the
individual user and and generally this is
sent directly to a client's preferred.
Destination.
So you know their SFTP or their portal
and they're you know they're based on a
you know data exchange agreement.
So there's probably limited ability for
us to you know share PLD via via a portal
like this because and there's also some.
Some handy, thanks for joining,
just getting started.
Some sensitivity around who is able to be
exposed to PLD as well. So,
so generally at our at our customers on
on the media side,
it's quite common that only.
A limited, you know,
group over there can actually, you know,
transact with with the physician level
data and be exposed to it.
Everyone else has to have, you know,
an aggregate view of the data.
So thought it was just good to kind of
level set there.
Good news about that is you know that
that process is largely.
Automated there's there's a good amount
of of validation that has to take place
and some obviously you know delivery of
the files that and all those things can't
be automated but you know that's that's
kind of the you know the table stakes
reporting that that that we start with
here at skipta.
Any questions on on the TLD? Yeah.
I mean, that's just some.
Yep. And uh, just.
But.
So I just got to ask you a really basic
question.
Please.
So where it says weekly or monthly
tactical level activity,
that's activity on the skip to platform
by these physicians, correct?
Excellent question and yes and no.
So that's actually one of the things that
OK.
I was was was going to kind of get more
in and and certainly will is just the
OK.
where the data comes from and what
channels it includes.
Sure.
So you know one of the things that is
somewhat unique about what we do or at
least makes it a little.
More complex is the the data coming from
multiple channels. So Jeremy, yes,
that is skipped on-site activity,
an e-mail activity,
but it is also programmatic media
activity.
So you know and that's honestly that's
that's the easiest thing, right?
Because that's just.
Questions.
And clicks and there's very little data
transformation or ETL that needs to
happen with that data.
But for the e-mail data,
for the onsite data and potentially for
like ad Butler data or ad server data,
although that's that's essentially you
know,
married with with the onsite or e-mail
data, you know those things.
They're all coming from, you know,
separate sources and have their own,
you know,
engagement definitions and criteria and
expectations from a reporting perspective.
OK. And just to clarify,
when you say programmatic media activity,
OK.
that's an ad gets served on a website to
a physician and they click on it. Yeah,
100%, Yep. So we do basically, you know,
off-site media campaigns to HC PS and you
OK.
know,
the brand safe places on the web that are
delivered via partners who are experts in
that space.
Right.
So we have a couple of programmatic media
partners.
Oh.
And you know you can envision we you have
other kind of you know partners to plug
in you know from an audience promotional
perspective whether they're you know
social companies who do something similar
like programmatic but it's you know it's
it's primarily you know exactly ad
delivery.
Free across the web.
Got it. OK, cool.
Any other questions about PLT?
Yeah. So and then then there's I, I,
I'm not sure if you mentioned it, Jake,
but there's the obviously there's the
vanilla out-of-the-box skipta PLD and
then there's the bespoke customer related,
yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, for sure. And I have,
I have a break on the on the next slide.
OK, yes.
Thank you, Spiro.
So the the next kind of level of
reporting is the aggregate data reporting.
So this is what is sent to you know the
the media planners and the and the
non-technical folks who are our primary
buyers at the.
Your team.
Or you know at the media agency but also
potentially directly to the client and
this is really the the the the details
and the context that we want to share
with with the partner to hopefully you
know again either goes directly to the
client or the good stuff makes its way to
the client.
But this is where you know we generally
have a lot more.
More flexibility here.
I say generally because there are there
are also client aggregate data templates
that are basically like their PLD process,
but just there's an aggregate data
process.
But what we're really talking about here
is you know,
monthly tactic and audience level
activity, you know, broken out by segment,
broken out by tactic.
That is also you know tracks to a
campaign goal as well.
So in this you know,
monthly documentation,
you know executive summary lays out the
campaign, what the goals are,
how we're pacing,
provides highlights each month and and
what we're really trying to do is.
You know, arm,
arm the agencies as best we can to tell
our story to the brand and and you know,
vouch for us because we're really trying
to, you know, overcome, you know,
what can be interpreted through the PLD
alone,
which sometimes isn't a favorable story
out of context, right.
So we're really trying to provide the
more holistic.
Context to to the campaign and I'll I'll
show you some some examples of what that
looks like and probably best to to jump
ahead a little bit now and we'll circle
back.
But so so this is like the PLD example
that Spiro was mentioning.
So this is just like a skip to standard
template. There's just.
Number of fields, it's not exhaustive.
This is kind of like the simplest
requirements in terms of you know who it
is, MPI, where they saw the thing,
you know what was the thing,
what they did, you know, timestamp,
Mhm.
whatever date.
So but client formats which are which are
very often the case for PLD are you know.
Based on their agreement and requirements
and again the process required to to
transmit the data as well and they can
have things like you know creative level
reporting with with unique identifiers or
multiple unique identifiers or you know
things like you know operating system or
device and.
And you know,
all those kind of things a client might
ask about across the channels that we
deliver.
So this is,
this is going back to that monthly
reporting again.
So as I mentioned you know you know
generally how we set it up and and what
what we'd love to be able to replicate
and further automate.
Honestly we've we've we've been kind of
really chipping away at the foundation
and the supporting data and processing.
This too.
To enable an advancement like this.
So you know we're we're we're excited for
Really.
the project and and to see if this is
actually what you guys had had envisioned
as well or or you know what we might have
to sacrifice or or phase out.
But again typically it's an executive
summary as is on the left side here
consent examples of these of course.
Of course too,
but you can see you know which
communities you know the term of the
campaign, the the the goal and the pacing,
some highlights,
a reminder of what they bought and and
how it's you know what how the
deliverable is assessed. So again,
not not sure all of this would make it
into this kind of interface, but.
You know this is this is what is
typically very helpful for us to keep the
campaigns in the right you know frame of
mind with our with our clients and then a
couple examples of you know tactic
specific sheets.
So I probably didn't specify this but
this this is typically delivered in Excel
format and the.
The way that and and the the the data
curation is is automated,
but obviously there's there's a level of
manual transposition that's happening
here.
But there are some some good reasons to
that in that it gives us, you know,
ultimate flexibility to customize the
columns and give the client exactly what
they want and it's very common for a
client to say.
Hey, you know, I I know this is views,
but I'd really love to see 3 plus second
views or five plus second views or you
know, 20% video completions or whatever,
right.
So that's that's one of the the
challenges that we have to kind of
automate this further is the level of
customization that our clients request
and it's one of those things where if a
client wants that and they're.
Looking at these, you know,
that is generally a great thing for
Skipton in terms of renewal.
So we don't want to disincentivize,
you know,
being able to have that that kind of
customization to the extent that it's
possible.
Are are those customization,
I'm just gonna call them requirements
from the client.
Are they for one client or are they
generally consistent over time?
Sure.
Comes in,
they see the world a slightly different
Sure.
way.
You know the the one client wants to
categorize a group of something as a
light engagement versus a versus a deep
engagement.
The next client on the same brand says,
you know, I don't really care about that.
They can all be engagements.
So there is there is some again some some
level that that just kind of expects.
Although there's certainly some room in
cases to also probably, you know,
push back a little bit on that. Again,
we've just, we've just been able to,
you know,
cater to to to the needs to the extent
that it's possible, you know,
with our with our clients, you know,
for for the most part.
Sometimes it's also just a semantics
thing too, Jeremy. Sometimes it's just,
you know, we know, you know,
this is the standard way we call
Sure.
something,
but we know the client prefers a
different verbiage.
And just as not to confuse them,
especially if it's going to the brand
client who might get just like peeved at
those kind of things like, hey, you know,
this is how I refer to this thing.
Stop trying to call this other thing like
some of those things are just like again
like campaign or client specific
customizations.
So, so, so Jake,
these seem to me mostly as customizable
Right.
configurable parameters, right?
So if we can define requirement that way,
Yep.
so for right.
So for example you know the I think what
OK.
you what you mentioned earlier was you
know along the lines of attribution
window.
Yeah.
And that where you know some people or or
you know what counts as a certain type of
engagement, right.
So I've dealt with for example customers
Yeah.
in the past who did not want to see any
view through you know convergence for
example,
right versus some customers that were
complete with OK with 100%.
Some wanted,
some would count something like, you know,
within two hours conversion because it
was very difficult to argue that someone
saw an ad instead of clicking on it,
they just opened a browser window and
they bought right. So,
so but but in the end, right,
100%, Yep.
what we ended up building was, you know,
a set of configurable.
Parameters you know are both around
different type of windows and different
type of actions.
So I think we we can define it that way
and then build a system that can allow
configuration per account or per customer
or per campaign or whatever we want to do
here, right? And then then it can.
Basically just be creating you know those
reports.
But.
I also want to you know understand and
this exact assembly assembly as well.
I think you know can mostly be automated
again if you can templatize it,
if you can define what are different
sections you know and and then it can be
OK.
configured.
You know, enable,
disabled for them at a campaign level and
what what what's the information that
goes there. So far I don't see anything,
Yep.
anything,
but I also want you know anything that
that cannot be done.
But I I I also want to understand how are
we joining, right,
which was the whole premise of you know
the the, the, the, this,
how are we joining?
The RWD data today right with these
campaign level metrics and what type of
Yep.
insights are we producing right? Uh,
you know,
super set of them will be awesome.
For sure.
Well you are you're teeing me up
beautifully so I'm I'm I'm just about to
get into that. So thank you.
So so skip this part for now although it
pertains to that but I have it broken out
in a better example.
Actually I'll I'll I'll show the pictures
first so.
Actually, no, I'll circle back there. So,
so essentially.
Once we have the the MPIs,
so assign to your point,
you're you know you're you're all over it,
right. It's just you know how do we,
how do we kind of account for all the
variables in the engagements and then
just kind of semantics wise,
how do we kind of cover what what things
are called and and how it shows up.
But basically for for us you know it all
starts with you know with with the MPIs
or I should say you know tracks back to
the MPIs as as the unique identifier.
You know we are just doing a lot of our
our our joins on our side from a
reporting perspective on on the user ID
which.
The e-mail address,
but obviously when we're when we're
trying to qualify activity from HEP
perspective,
we're tracking back to the unique MPI.
You know all the HEPS that that we
interact with are are you have an MPI at
least to to to this point.
So essentially what we are doing is on a
periodic basis.
Basis because we don't have this part you
know automated to be reflected back in
that in that monthly reporting yet
something we were thinking about but you
know may be able to accomplish here of
course based on what we're doing Hassan
and Jeremy is you know taking those lists
of MPIs which are either you know based
on exposures.
Or actions or you know what we call
engagements and basically taking those to
show the like the patients treated
historically just as a just to get a
sense of you know kind of you know these
are the right HCP. So basically trying to.
Quantify the the patient treatment
behavior kind of at at a minimum we'll do
that.
And then it's just a question of do we
look at you know prescribing behavior or
procedural behavior as is relevant and
and you know there are some ways that
that we can essentially do that here but.
Again,
so basically we're saying you know what's
the number of HCPS we reached,
how does what's the percent or you know
or or engaged again kind of depending on
how you pull it,
how does that track as a percentage to
the target list which is you know the
group of of HCPS we intended to engage or
or expose your messaging to?
Put that into some frequency calculations
cause you know that's that's something
important to summarize.
So you know you know views for HCP or
engage for HCP and then we basically say
OK you know of those HC PS who were
exposed or engaged, you know XYZ, right.
So here's their,
here's their you know treatment history
of patients with Alzheimer's.
Disease over the prior 12 months and then
and then kind of throw that into a
frequency as well.
So that's kind of like the the minimum
that we'll do and this is actually when
we talk about like identifying potential
additional segments of HCPS.
One of the ways that this is actually
really helpful is if we have already done
that.
So there are often cases where we have a
group of HC PS participating in the
program that are skipped the sourced
based on their patient treatment
behaviors or prescribing behaviors or or
other RWD.
So you know we're already we're already
doing that and this is always a good
opportunity to remind the client and
reinforce.
You know why they're doing that, right?
So it's it's one,
it's good to just to kind of try to take
stock and and translate to real people
and real patients in terms of your
potential future behavior based on your
historic behavior. But you know it's also,
you know, helpful to, you know,
take care of the other, the other,
you know.
Pieces as well from from that perspective.
So the other I should say so that's
that's a patient treatment perspective
and then there's essentially what do you
do in terms of you know scripts written
or or procedures performed right and and
honestly at the scale that we work.
With you know it's not always the easiest
thing to to show that in a in a favorable
way versus a control group.
So you know it it really depends on the
situation and and the feasibility,
but you know we may also using the.
What we've worked on with with the RWD
data science team,
you know do a script lift methodology
based on you know change in prescribing
behaviour over time.
I think I think you know that is a little
trickier to accomplish and and actually.
You know quantifying scripts written or
for those HC PS who are care team members
like you know scripts influenced like and
being able to automate that would be
would be a great initial step because
obviously that is just you know based off
the MPI or having a shared patient with
an with an MPI if if we kind of did the
the the route for the.
Care team and that would be significantly
more data than than these clients
typically have on their programs in a
near real-time basis, right?
Like it's very rare for them to even see,
well,
here's your historic patient treatment
behavior.
It's significantly more rare to have a
have a and and I think exciting to have a.
Vendor who is proactively sharing the,
you know,
script impact or or at least the you know
total script impact,
you know not not for the control group
over time from the HC PS that are you
know being reached with the messaging for
the for the given vendor.
So is script in fact pretty much the de
facto optimization metric here for all
these campaigns or are there others?
Well, it's a fascinating question.
So it's actually not because it's not
readily available and obtainable across
all tactics and partners.
But but you know you're hitting on
something that if if you did have this
scale like that's a great story to tell
to the client that we're optimizing your
campaign based on based on actual
prescribing behavior what.
Yes.
Essentially happens in the real world.
Hassan is you know they're they're making
optimizations off of you know proxies,
you know media metrics in terms of you
know click rate and and all those things
right.
Action based you know metrics and and the
the prescribed behavior is such a lagging
metric that you know you don't.
Find out till 12 months later how you
performed on their script left exercise,
right.
So there's and and and some of that is
Yeah.
also just the practical part of some of
these campaigns or you know hundreds of
oncologists.
So given the challenges of even getting
that data but also at that scale
sometimes these are it just it's just not
a feasible measurement you know and and.
And oftentimes we're dealing with rare
disease or smaller groups.
So that's where I feel like I don't know
if maybe that is the attack on component
and an upsell opportunity to be able to,
you know,
enable some script lift measurement or
optimize based off of an actual script
lift versus control.
But I think at a minimum if we were able.
Pull it off, you know, tracking those,
those scripts or again,
I think they have very limited visibility
if it's not the actual prescriber, right.
They don't,
they don't have no idea what the nurses
and the PAS are doing and and that is
also lagging data they're getting from
IQVIA several months later, right.
So we were also able to say, hey.
And for your, you know, N PS or PC PS,
here's the scripts they're influencing,
right.
So that allows us to take
disproportionate credit versus our
competitors for, you know,
the messages we're getting in front of
those, you know, care team HC PS,
for example.
Yep, makes makes sense.
So the the landing page is almost always
OK.
a skipped up property right now, correct?
Or you know,
because I remember discuss you know some
discussions around the creative taking
you know the click to the you know the
customer side directly.
Is it?
So, so good, so good question. So,
so for that,
for that programmatic media part that we
had talked about,
we leveraged the programmatic media
partners in two ways.
So one of them is to drive you know
traffic back to our our platform.
So that's not the data we would be
talking about here,
but that that media is, is going.
To the partner website.
So that is that is that is you know like
I mean I guess all their banners click to
the partner website but you know that is
that is not happening on the skip to
platform that is going to the partner
site.
The one one tactic that we have is a
partner micro site.
So it's you know it's their.
It's their page that they designate
enabled in our platform via an iframe.
So in that they're still visiting the
skip the property,
they just are also visiting the client's
site at the same time.
So all that data is tracked through
through us.
Good. So the reason I made, yeah,
the reason I made made that comment is
that right there. So,
so there are you know, very, you know,
straightforward but somewhat shallow
engagement metric like clicks, right.
And of course you know viewing.
Uh, the impressions and stuff like that.
But then there are there and and and the
ideal is you know script writing,
but it's like so if we can define some
sort of a standard way of uh of providing
a deeper engagement metric of some sort
um like uh and include that,
I think that could be.
Evaluate and and and but when when I say
deeper right I've you know seen things
like there is let's say a sub website
right.
So so so so you click on you land on some
page but then there are there is a form
that the customer submits or there are
bunch of secondary pages like that.
Yep.
You would click on and go.
So which basically indicates more time
spent,
right or and you deploy a pixel there,
right,
which you know could call be called,
you know,
secondary engagement pixel or conversion
pixel, whatever you want to call it.
But then we can show,
we can optimize on that, right,
'cause that would be more readily
available,
would be a subset of people that are
clicking.
Right.
So that's one one thing that often works,
Yep.
especially if it can show a higher level
of interest in the product or something,
But.
No, it's it's it's a great point.
We do provide those metrics and we'll
right?
certainly go through kind of all the
standard metrics,
but things like you know questions
answered and comments and some of the
action oriented things that you know not
necessarily depth of visit,
Yes.
but I do have to,
I do have to like I have to kind of set
expectations there.
There in that it sounds great Ahsan and
it and it and it can be great if you're
working with scale,
but just the the scale that we see,
you are generally seeing very little of
that behavior and very shallow.
Experiences.
So you know we we have we have users who
Got it.
go real deep and stick around for several
minutes or several hours.
We also have way more users who are there
for a second right or you know or and
Yep.
don't do anything.
So you know it's one of those and and
it's also the other part of is I always
say it's it's it's a math problem in that.
You know.
We might have a campaign for oncologists
where, you know, we expect to get,
you know,
500 views on a custom asset over the
course of, you know, five months.
Now in that 500 views, just again,
just just the math,
I actually don't expect anyone to click
on a link in there just because the the
benchmark.
For for that kind of behavior or right or
or I guess in that you know it's it's
Sir.
like 1% right.
So we got we get like 5 clicks in that
Done.
example.
So and then it's like if you want even a
deeper engagement behind that like you're
you're not going to get any but it is it
Yeah, under understood.
is the right way to be thinking about it.
It's just then you have to say OK.
Again what is what is kind of the
standard way you show it if because you
don't want to you don't want to nudge the
client to look at those things if it's if
it's not a favorable story and and those
things and not to be and it's not it's
Yeah, no, I.
not honestly just to skip the problem
it's it's a scale of the audiences and
also just how you know a physician
behaves.
Your problem or you know just consumer
behavior right now and I think the the
nice thing about the some of the
programmatic stuff is if you can get that
OK.
scale and impression delivery and the
clicks and and then you have a a a much
larger scale potentially of those
sequential actions.
So you know,
it's just it's just something to keep in
mind, but I like what you're thinking.
Yeah, no, it makes perfect sense. I mean,
I'm and I was referring to opportunities
Hmm.
where scale is available, right? You know,
like programming, so.
Well,
and and and just a a way simpler way to
think about it too is just something like
average time spent.
Like we will have to think like do we
want to show that in in a summary if you
What?
know there's a chance that the campaign's
been running for a month and that numbers
really doesn't look great and out of
context,
we actually don't want to show it in the
dashboard, so.
So there's those types of considerations
where sometimes we're, you know,
trying to tell the best story possible.
And sometimes it's something simple as,
you know,
the client's creative actually has
nowhere to click in it,
so there's going to be 0 clicks.
So it's nice in the Excel format to be
able to remind the client of that and
show.
A screenshot and say hey, oh by the way,
you know zero clicks are expected here
because there's nowhere to click in this
thing.
Like that's the kind of context that
sometimes can be really helpful just to
keep from like a campaign getting getting
cancelled.
Honestly the and I'll go back and show
you some of the script lifts and ROI
stuff,
but but basically then what we'll do.
Is again,
we'll we'll execute that ROI script lift
measurement versus a control that we
worked on, you know,
having a methodology with the data
science team. And you know,
it's one of those things where again,
the audiences are so small,
you know you're not always guaranteed to
have a, you know, a positive script lift.
And it's one of those things and and
again it's sometimes the the you know the
scale of the actual delivery is so small
and so what are you really basing that
behaviour change on anyway.
So there is some consideration about when
it makes sense to use those and with
where is it feasible and and and where is
it only directional.
And it's certainly not industry standard
to, you know,
proactively provide a script lift ROI
measurement,
although it can certainly help support
your case, especially if you can do it,
you know,
more more readily than than others can in
terms of lag time.
Couple other Yeah, please, Jeremy.
Are you pulling?
Are you accessing the RWD production
database for for this? OK,
so you're just going straight to the
Yes, yes.
database, join on MPIs,
pulling with data you need,
That's exactly right.
That's exactly right. And and spiro,
calculating your metrics, OK.
you know we we have the the queries for
it and it really just becomes you know
how are you creating your your sample
group, right.
Because there is there is sometimes when
you do this that you know you don't want
to take all exposed MPI,
you want to qualify those to some extent
say we want the three plus you know
exposure.
Or whatever and and try to then base your
analysis off of that.
Right.
You know there's some of those
considerations and then it's just about
you know aligning to the the scripts and
and matching back to the control group
you know which is based on HCPS with with
similar you know pre.
Precampaign prescribing characteristics.
But still more we could do there, yeah.
Are you are you maintaining?
So when you you say you know other MPIs
with similar prescribing characteristics,
so I'm that's got to be an aggregation of
what's in the database because I've
looked at the database.
That's right.
So are you maintaining that aggregation?
Are you doing it on the fly?
Do you have a, you know, pivoted view?
That shows things by NPI and calculates
aggregations and so forth.
Spiro,
can you speak to how that part works in
terms of setting up the control group
offhand?
No.
Yep. In real world data,
you're talking about the cohort. Yeah,
Yep, Yep.
yeah.
So we we had originally had gotten a
script from Akshay and we we use that
kind of as a template and it's a based
off of age and.
I think graduate the year of graduation
possibly and a few other parameters that
that were that were set and that that's
how they they actually they get the
cohorts.
So it doesn't sound like like it's going
against aggregated tables.
It sounds like that's just querying the
database.
Yeah, it's querying the database, correct.
Yeah,
we could maybe dive into the technical
details later,
but the thing that I'm curious about is
No.
you've got your list of.
I assume when you say cohort,
that's a list of MPIs.
You've got your list of MPIs.
How do you build a picture of an API?
You're talking about, you know,
comparing based on previous subscribing
behaviour.
And obviously you can go into claims or
other data sources,
but where does that aggregation sit?
Is it done on the fly?
Is it a temporary table that you maintain?
Is it a data bit?
Yeah, it's done. No, no,
it's done on the fly as per per script
lift. Yeah, per script lift.
Everything's done on the. Yeah,
OK.
it's not already pre aggregated.
Now we we crunch the numbers,
we join the numbers,
we compare it all all at at that at the
time of script lift run. Yep.
Got it. OK. Thank you.
Yep, Yep.
Sure.
So a lot of our clients,
the bigger ones are again performing
Sure.
these exercises or having a third party
do it.
Of course it's just it's just another way
to to dimensionalize the behavior right
that I that I think again if you're using
kind of total counts,
you know there's a way to to tell a good
story without without it versus control.
And you know but but yeah it certainly it
certainly gets better if you have a
communicating control and and be
confident in it whether whether you know
just how how far does it go with a client
is ultimately the question but it can
Great.
certainly can certainly kind of keep you
from from the chopping block if if things
aren't trending the right way so can be.
Need to have in your back pocket,
you know,
or use out of necessity in certain cases.
And when you think about a control group,
you're thinking about HC PS with similar
Goodbye.
characteristics profiles to the ones that
are part of the campaign,
but that were not part of the campaign.
That's exactly right, yes.
So because the only thing we have
exposure to, right, is, is, is, you know,
who we didn't expose the campaign to.
So that's what really makes this,
you know, tricky,
especially in terms of scale, right?
Because we don't know that those other
Yeah.
HCPS hadn't been hit, you know,
50 times from our competitors because
everyone's trying to reach the same, same,
same group of it, you know, 500.
On.
Yeah.
But we just know that we didn't reach
them in that period. What makes it,
you know, even trickier sometimes is,
you know,
obviously we're working with clients for
multiple years. You know,
our ability to have a control who hasn't
been influenced, you know,
just kind of goes, goes down over time.
So sometimes those things are just are
Yes.
just, you know, challenging.
If you're trying to look at the data in
that way.
Yeah.
Yeah, if you do this perfectly,
which will never happen,
but if you do this perfectly,
there is no control group because you've
hit everybody.
Yeah, yeah, totally.
And and again that's why I think,
Yeah.
I think having total scripts is is more
defensible or total procedures again or
or total scripts influencing because
because the the care team is such a blind
spot and a lot of these brands are trying
to say, OK,
you know we've we've got the
pulmonologist now we've really got to get
the.
PCP.
Who influences that behavior or whatever,
right.
So having having some having that linkage
through the common you know shared
patient data I think would be a a great
differentiator.
And if you're doing it on you know a
whole script standpoint versus a lift,
you know it's like hey this is this is
the data, right.
We're not we're not calculating anything
here. This is this is the prescribing.
Behavior. So now I get it.
I mean sometimes the challenge with that
is you control what you can control and
you know some of these brands,
you know that goes in the opposite
direction than they'd like.
So that's kind of the other thing about
the deeper you show these things that
Yeah.
again,
it's not always positive and it's not
always a, you know, a problem.
Has control over.
Sometimes the brand just doesn't perform
right. And then it's like, well,
did you want to have a big old negative
whatever percent or or so or you know,
no no scripts over time.
So some of those considerations are also,
you know,
kept in mind when we think about scaling
this across, you know,
everything that we do.
Yeah, makes sense. Look,
a lot of this stuff can be configurable
OK.
Oh, for sure, yeah. Well, yeah.
and can also be built over right,
built over time.
So I think at least for the first release
we should focus on low hanging fruits.
You know,
things that we know everyone can benefit
from.
They do reduce time right to put this
Yep.
together and hopefully get to deeper
insights and recommendations.
That we don't have today, right. So,
so yeah, so,
Yep, that's great.
so starting from you know the so maybe
and and and Jeremy,
I think it's a follow up, right.
You know because we have like 20
something minutes remaining but you can
dive deep into later on dive deep into
you know the reports, the the joins,
the information we are pulling.
Right.
And the the the the goal is to produce a
requirement document that we can start
basically assign some team members right
OK.
once we have the funding and and start
building it literally and the requirement
document have to consider what we can
automate from what you guys do today.
Plus, what's the additional value add,
right? So let's let's have both. Um, yeah,
Awesome.
that would be the goal.
No, that's great.
And and if I have a couple more things
from an insight perspective,
I want to touch on because I think it's
helpful to share.
But then I I do have a section here just
on you know kind of you know challenges
that I think will be good to talk about
you know data ingestion and kind of and
some of we talked we we touched on
already but I think it would be a good
way to close and and probably some good
questions around it so so.
Hassan,
you you had kind of alluded this at one
point before in terms of creative
performance,
but of course there's insights that can
come from that common one would be,
you know,
subject line for emails or something,
right? So again, maybe not a phase one,
but this is just under the the umbrella
of, you know, audience insights, you know,
particular creative level insights.
And then another which which we do not do
now kind of systematically it's you know
kind of ad hoc when something really
sticks out.
But a couple other things that are that
are really helpful to provide more
context for our programs are analysis of
HCP commentary or their quiz behavior.
So these are things that are.
You know we'll we'll leverage AI
oftentimes.
I mean our our model's pretty well
trained so there's not a lot of honing
that needs to be done to the output.
But obviously like it's it's much easier
now to to plug these in you know comments
with with the right prompt and get a get
a you know client facing deliverable you
know.
Sum.
Size of the HCP commentary. So, so,
so that and then you know their their
quiz behavior and essentially you know
what they did well,
what they didn't do so well,
what that tells us about the audience
like these give us some some nice,
you know,
deeper engagement data to then base
insights off of and they're often a kind
of a program hack for us.
Us in that, you know, it's a it's a very,
it's a it's a fairly small percentage of
the audience who who does these types of
things, right,
versus everyone we're engaging.
But it really allows us to tell that
story more effectively and say, hey,
you know,
here's the collaboration that's taking
place within this discussion and here's
what we're learning,
here's what HCPs are learning.
learning, here's what you can learn.
You know, those types of things can be,
you know, invaluable,
especially when you're trying to get past
the scale problem or, you know,
why didn't you have any clicks this month
or whatever. You know,
those things that shouldn't just happen
with with these types of executions.
Does that make sense?
And then when we are thinking about,
you know,
what do we know about the audience, right?
I think that's that's an area that would
require a lot of, you know, deep dive.
So to because then the goal is to come up
with recommendations, right? So, so,
so that would require at least a
splitting into two rough groups.
Yep.
The group,
the group that's performing and engaging
the way we want them to and what are
their characteristics and how do we
It.
identify unique characteristics of the
group that that that's not doing what we
want them to.
And then you know from the first group we
can go and find similar providers right
that are currently not in the target set.
Yeah.
So but.
No, I think that's really,
it's really interesting. I think,
I think we want to make sure we're trying
to do that in a way that you know builds
on what we have and and doesn't
incentivize tailoring down what we have
because that is something where you know
a client could could come back and say
well you know.
Let's just pull,
let's just do that one segment anyway and
let's cut this program in a third,
you know,
because that's the one that's doing.
So it's but there is.
Yeah, yeah, that's that's marketing,
right. So we can,
so we can basically just say, you know,
you can present one side of it.
Yeah.
OK.
We will need to know the both sides for
internal purposes,
but the but the system can simply say
here are these additional providers that
are more likely to convert.
Yeah.
Would you like to explain?
No, no, I I think that's great.
I actually that was my last bull you know
Yeah.
whatever we intend to do with the look
alike or you know act alike HC PS to
subject more, subject more audience.
Obviously that would that would be an
insight or you know could could could
build off of these insights that that we
The.
were talking about.
So yeah again but that that is kind of
the the problem that we.
We generally face is is you know trying
to have bigger,
more relevant audiences and not but but
generally we are actively telling that
Yeah.
data story. Again,
it's just it's just not happening in an
automated way and certainly not through
you know a platform like this,
but again care care team or based on
patient treatment behaviour or based on
OK.
shared patients.
Is you know something we're we're doing a
good amount of which you know can can be
tough in terms of you know clients
preference for you know target list
engagement there there's only so much
appetite to to go beyond but I I know
we've we've discussed that too.
PG.
Yeah, please.
Sorry.
So like one of the things we talked about
in that meeting in New York,
like the premise of this would be to and
it may be through like a sample,
you give them a one time freebie,
but basically you know you have their
target list on who they want to reach and
let's say we extend that and identified,
you know, another cohort of.
doctors that we think are that would
perform as well, if not better,
which would extend their audience or
improve it,
and then just run the run the program for
those extra like a value add as a one
time and then be able to go back and show
them the engagement metrics or however
deep we could go, whether it's leading
Indicator engagement metrics are all the
way down to script and show them that,
hey, look, you know,
this is what you guys had and now you can
see what you would have gotten if you
would have leveraged our data.
Yeah,
I don't think you can do it in that way
You know what I mean? And.
for most clients because you'd have to
make them aware of of where their media
is is going and who it's being exposed to.
But I I do think what you could do is in
Right.
an automated way, you know,
quantify that upsell opportunity and say,
hey, you know, reach.
Back out to your skip to sales,
you know representative to to learn more
whatever and then basically have that be
a lead generation you know mechanism that
our internal team can check on too and
say hey you know looks like there's 5000
more docs who are who have this lab
behavior that you're not targeting you
know any interest you know I I think the
idea of that is is.
Is is really compelling because that is
something that we're doing on an ad hoc
basis.
Now now oftentimes there there are good
reasons for the ad hoc nature in terms of
their highly customized requests.
You know it's it's usually not as simple
as you know them them wanting us to be
prescriptive and and here's the audience,
but there's obviously there's.
There's room for that and I think that's
a very, very cool idea.
I just think we'd have to keep the
governor unless there's a another version
of this which is, you know,
activating that audience, you know,
immediately based on based on business
rules that are set up in advance or you
So yeah.
Yeah.
know,
having the ability to activate it right
in the platform.
Form, you know,
leveraging our next best action, you know,
capabilities and that kind of stuff.
Yeah,
and and there's probably a couple ways to
do it. And I agree,
I know they have to know who you're who
you're promoting to.
You can't just do it whatever you want.
But if like just like if we said,
you know,
we were going to go to full community
instead of just their target list,
that's almost like a value add for them.
We could kind of let them know up front
that we, you know, who who we would.
Go out to and then just show them the
results afterwards. I don't know, but um.
No, we can do that now, but yeah, no.
And then doing that in in this kind of a
display or you know would would be would
be really great. And again,
I think it's one of the benefits too
would just be giving exposure to you know
the commercial team so they can.
You know,
use that as reasons to go down the
pavement and say, look,
look what else we can we can do for you.
Look how good,
look how good this other audience is
working.
Yeah,
just like giving them a little taste and
then then that would make them want to
use the tool,
either license the tool and you know the
that model or have us, you know, build,
help them build the non personal list and
then promote to it, you know.
E.
So I don't know, just a thought,
but that's that was kind of.
I I feel like this Monday come up in our
prior conversation or Frank probably
mentioned it.
But another thing that we that we do is
you know next best action or engagement
which is just you know you know mostly
triggered media or media based on.
On your execution based on on data inputs
from the client or skipped activity or
real world data.
So it is really compelling and you know
we're already basically you know,
triggering emails for example based on
lab behaviour.
The idea that you could do that in a more
efficient way or at least scope it and
then have it still go through you know.
The sales entity,
whatever again is is very compelling and
certainly makes it much more scalable,
you know,
than than it currently is to kind of tee
up those opportunities.
But we have a basically a data cloud
project.
That that's about to get kicked off to
help us harmonize that data in the
execution.
So it's it's much more conceivable to see,
you know,
whatever output is generated here to be
turfed over into data cloud to enable
execution in in a pretty seamless way.
Yeah.
So couple,
couple other thoughts as I mentioned and
certainly jump in aside or Jeremy if
there's something else critical you you
definitely want to get to on this call.
But I did just want to share some of the
barriers.
It's something we talked about in terms
of.
Relation to channel.
So you know some of this data just lives
in different places.
We do actually have a project underway to
create a master reportable data
materialized view to basically pull
together some disparate data sets and and
overcome a little bit of the of the
challenges with with some of the tables
we're working with.
What is what is reportable mean here?
Um.
Excellent question. So again,
so so I think this is also part of the
challenge of of working with additional
channels beyond like the programmatic
media channel where impressions and
clicks are pretty straightforward so.
For example you know e-mail data and
on-site data both you know is is curated
and and transformed and and you know
scrubbed in various ways.
So the simplest example is you know like
for e-mail data.
Removing you know suspicious click
activity,
potential bot activity based on you know
you know behaviors within the e-mail.
So you know there is a you know there is
a you know logic that you know transforms
the raw Salesforce data into client
facing reportable data that is that is
taken care of some of those you know.
Data anomalies. So an example would be,
you know,
Got it.
OK.
a single user clicks 37 times on the same
link.
Yeah.
We don't want that making it into the
hands of our clients,
Yeah.
so that is systematically removed from
the reporting.
Another example could simply be like you
know there are there are opens without a
corresponding send for whatever reason
just because of you know.
You know some piece of data got lost
along the way from Salesforce and the
system.
So it's you know manufacturing that send
record to a company, the open record,
you know kind of you know things like
Yeah, got it.
that.
Now for onsite data it's it's
significantly more complex because.
You know, we are basically, you know,
scrubbing for, you know,
bots in various forms,
including those who are suspected based
on their their IP address and and
Internet behaviors. That helps us.
Very much in terms of removing anomalies
from the data. So similar wonky things,
you know one single HCPS 500 visits in
two seconds,
you know it's we don't want that making
it into the report and and and skewing
the data.
And then there's also you know things
like you know requirements in terms of
those you know report you know reportable
views so so.
Essentially.
You know, having a, you know,
time-based measurement of the activity.
So we're not counting, you know,
10 views on a single post within 10
OK.
seconds. You know, we count, you know,
one view every 30 seconds,
whatever the methodology is for for the
tactic.
So there's a series of and and there's
some, you know, there's various kind of.
Related parts of that,
but just to give you an idea,
that curation is happening and the data
is being put into, you know,
materialized view.
Now one of the that that is great for a
lot of reasons gives us a ton of
flexibility as the data changes and the
No.
methodology changes for for processing it.
One of the challenges though,
is that necessitates having a monthly
archival process where we're essentially
closing the books on the prior month.
So that data is never changing
retroactively and kind of screwing up our
reporting down the line.
But that basically requires you kind of
more a little bit more complexity in
terms of, you know, referring.
Back to the prior closed months versus
kind of the currently active month in
terms of how the data is is organized.
Is that helpful?
Cool.
Other just kind of you know just kind of
where we are right now is something that
we we've been working to improve Andy's
team's been doing an excellent job in
terms of you know data pipelines and data
availability and and and monitoring the
data,
Excellent.
but it's just kind of the practical fact
of you know.
Where we are coupled with you know the
number of data sources you know these
things aren't aren't always aren't always
live.
You know the I would say you know once
every you know two months or so probably
there's there's an issue where something
needs to be back filled or reconnected or
you know there's a release that that jams
something up.
So we we had been putting in as.
As many alerts and flags as we possibly
can. But you know, Murphy's Law,
you know this something will inevitably
go happen that trips something up.
So it's just it's just a note on data
availability because again,
I think in the programmatic world,
it's just, you know,
having data available nearly, you know,
100% of the time is just par for the
course and that's not necessarily the
case with.
Like you know processing the onsite data
and e-mail data and we basically have
like a 48 hour lag time and that's
because we're getting at the time what
we're getting from partners and also with
our data processes and it's kind of you
know TBD how much we could we could
potentially trim that down and still be
comfortable.
So where you know it it kind of begs the
question of.
You know is is client facing quote UN
quote real-time data a future phase and
and is it should it now be you know that
should that be internal only potentially
and then the client gets a a monthly
report that has a chance to be validated
and and and you know and and looked over
before it's shared.
So obviously that that.
Cuts into some of the automation,
but it's just, you know,
there are very few thankfully in this
space who who even do, you know,
quote UN quote,
real-time dashboards for this kind of
stuff and and they tend to be, you know,
the heaviest hitters in the space, right?
Like Doximity and Medscape can do it,
but I don't think anybody else does it.
So it's not like that's a that's a
requirement.
It's more of can we can we plot a course
to get there with our with our data
availability and you know portal
availability.
But I think again showing reports on a
monthly basis and and having them
available internally more readily would
would be an excellent start.
What's your timeline for that? Sorry,
for the master reportable table?
And then the last thing is please.
What's the, broadly speaking,
the timeline on that?
So we actually we we should be done by
October 15th and and likely sooner. Yeah.
Cool.
And and and a lot of the and a lot of the
underlying tables are already built.
So and and the good news is, yeah.
OK.
So just a matter of pulling them all
together, yeah.
That's right.
And and and the good thing about that is
OK, cool.
we kind of really got our ducks in a row
in terms of you know the common fields
across across all the disparate channels
and and kind of you know having those you
know harmonized in a way that that we're
comfortable with.
So that's you know a a good, a good,
a good step I think to facilitate this.
And then the other just kind of thing
that just happens again kind of goes back
to the customization.
But you know because of these various
factors there are just needs for manual
adjustments.
So we would have to just have you know a
way to you know update that data where
when we need to an example.
Would be like, hey, you know, a bot,
you know, slipped by,
caused something wonky in the data for
some reason, didn't get, you know,
caught in one of the filters that we have.
We have limited time.
Are we processing the whole, you know,
materialized table again or are we
changing that, you know, 120 to a 10 or?
10 or whatever to account for the 110
views from from the pop getting out of
there, right.
So these are just things that just kind
Yeah.
of pop up again that that I think are you
know just par for the course for for more
complex executions like these.
But you know again having the Excel has
given us ultimate flexibility
historically to handle those so.
It's a it's, you know,
we're curious how well we could
accommodate that kind of stuff in,
you know, more automated way like this.
Well, I know I talked your ears off.
Any any other,
any other questions or or things you'd
want to cover as we as we close?
Oh.
Actually, do do we?
Are we going till 3:20 or did I?
I booked it 90 minutes,
but we can just stop whenever you know.
Yeah,
cause I'm I'm good to keep going if if if
you have questions or would like to.
Yeah. I mean,
everything that I see makes sense,
Yeah.
broadly speaking. And I think that.
So there's a couple of things that would
be really helpful for me. What is,
can I get access to the platform so I can
log in?
You know, use it, see what users see,
experience what users experience in a way
that doesn't screw up your data,
hopefully,
but that would be really helpful.
That table that you know,
then the other one to ask for is.
Database or access, but as you said,
you're working on updating the data to
this new master table format.
So if you have documentation on that you
can share, that would be helpful.
And then you know in a month or so we
talk about query access.
And then examples, yes,
like you're showing at screw right now,
like examples of the PLD level
deliverable and the aggregated
Mm.
deliverable so that I can study them more
closely.
Cool. Yeah, happy to do it. And and Jimmy,
I I think you know other than the
challenge we laid out just trying to
conceive how we can you know get all
these tactics in a dashboard and and even
if one of the things that we've been kind
of playing around is just even
consolidating this type of thing and and
trying to get into you know as few.
Pages as possible, but there's just,
you know,
a decent amount of columns and a decent
amount of rows and they're not,
they're not standardized across across
every tactic.
Yeah.
So I think there is just a bit of this is
just a how do we display the data and
give the level of, you know,
tactic level or audience level
granularity that is expected and.
Still, you know,
have it display in in portal fashion and
not require you know all these tabs and
everything.
Hey, Jeremy,
what type of platform do you envision?
Like do you envision it being like you
start with a standard report and then
being able to customize or drag or do it
like what kind of you know to be able to
accommodate like let's say you know 70 to
80% of the reports.
Pretty.
Standard and then maybe 20% of them we
have to like switch stuff and I don't
know if that 702080207030 is even
accurate,
but just assuming that the majority are
standard and then the other ones have to
be customized,
how are you envisioning that? Like,
is there a platform that you'd be able to
easily?
Customize so that 70% of them pop out
standard or 100% pop out standard and you
you can easily customize the other 20 or
30% that have like nuances to them.
I mean, yeah, that makes sense.
So you know,
if the idea of going from deliverable via
these Excel files to deliverable via some
platform that users log into.
I I I think the idea of using
configurations like I saw as I saw
mentioned, I think is the key.
And so defining that configuration model,
Yeah.
what does it look like?
How much do you let the user do it
themselves versus having a?
You know somebody on our side help them
with it or configure it for them and then
Right.
tied to you know it should be tied to
assuming that one client equals one
configuration, which may not be the case.
I don't know.
Then you know you have that tied to their
login and they can see what they expect
to see.
you know, when they log in.
Yeah, good, good. Sorry, Franka.
Yeah, is this some? Is this?
No, I was just gonna say,
are are there specific platforms that
exist that you're considering or is this
like a custom build?
I mean, I think it's,
I mean that's a good question.
I think that we would want to see some
sort of so if if so if this is going to,
if we're going to move from delivering
this via you know the things you said
SMTP, Excel files,
you know data let's say instead of
delivering data we're delivering.
you a URL that you log into that you then
access that data and maybe you can
download it into other things too.
There has to be some user experience
research, I think,
around what that looks like and making
sure that we design that workflow so that
it suits what the user is trying to do.
So I mean,
it doesn't sound that complicated,
frankly,
unless there's pieces of it that I'm
missing, but.
Yeah, I think we would need.
We would need a designer to help us with
that.
Yeah. And in terms of the platform itself,
right,
Well, in a listen.
Yes.
there may be options that we can just
adopt to and customize or we may build
custom.
I think we should keep the door open.
It really depends on, you know,
I think we need more detailed
requirements to determine that in in the
past frankly I ended up in vast majority
Yeah.
of the cases I ended up building
something custom.
Because it was the platforms are either
costly or slow or, you know,
Yeah.
there were just all kind of reasons,
sometimes not enough customizable. Yep.
Right.
By the time you actually get what you
want, might as well just build it.
Yeah, yeah.
And your users are very specific, so.
Yeah.
Well and and Jeremy to circle back to
your other question. So,
so that is one of the one,
one of the complications is because our
like the media clients that we work with,
they might be on multiple brands who
cover multiple manufacturers.
So basically like you know I I work for
CMI, I am on Pfizer, their oncology.
I also am in I I cover Genentech,
you know their PCP brands, whatever.
So I might be on you know a few different
reports that have you know some different
configurations.
So that's just something like yeah,
now you would be able to handle that I'm
sure.
In terms of you know dial,
you know drilling down at the campaign
level,
but it it just it's probably you wouldn't
be able to kind of align it at a user
level just just in in some you know in a
fair amount of cases just to kind of
answer that answer that question.
Yeah,
so some some would be part of some other
groups.
If you set up some groups that would,
Yeah,
I mean the other thing I would just say
that would probably work, yeah.
Yeah.
is I'm I'm like,
I'm very stoked to have you guys
assisting with this project because this
has been something we've conceived of for
Mhm.
for a while as we've chipped away at all
the underlying kind of precursor steps to
get here.
So the the timing is actually really
great to to have.
You guys involved now we're we're super
thankful.
But I I would say there there's also
probably a version of this concept that
is more about the insights that is
basically you know generating those
insights based off the exposed or engaged
engaged MPI's that's you know
significantly more simplistic in terms of
you know it not being.
Being our monthly reporting portal.
That said,
I mean again I I think I think having the
monthly reporting portal is is a super
helpful and also a significantly better
you know front porch so to speak to get
users into the experience and then tee up
other things because we know they're
going to come get those monthly reports.
So I.
I do.
I do love that, but you know,
if we for some reason can't get there,
we could potentially, you know,
pivot to focusing more on the insights
generated from the just the MPIs engaged
or exposed,
which is significantly easier to pipe
into whatever query we need to do and
then and then you know,
summarize in in the portal, but just.
Yeah.
Just a thought in terms of a Plan B.
Yeah, I mean in my.
So I mean there's a lot to learn
Yeah.
obviously still,
but in my head this sits in kind of three
broad phases.
So one is what can with continuing the
same delivery mechanism that you have now,
what can we automate?
Considering the same delivery mechanism
that you have now, what value can we add?
What insights and value can we add?
And then the phase beyond that is,
you know,
updating the delivery mechanism to this
portal that you described,
which uses that data but presents it in a.
Different way, basically.
Does that make sense?
Yeah, it certainly does.
OK.
So, so Jeremy in the first one,
it can also be sort you know the the UI
can still be built but for internal use
so that so the customer don't see
OK.
anything change right?
But we built something that internal
Yeah, for sure. For sure.
OK.
Thank you.
users,
you know admin users per se can take
configure maybe not everything is built.
But yeah.
Yeah.
And we do,
we do have you know we have internal
facing Tableau dashboards.
It's just again the challenge is having
all that data live in the same place and
be performing and be you know look right
visually.
So there is there's something to do I I
think I think it's you know internal
facing need is is certainly.
Critical and exposing more of our
internal folks to campaign performance or
allowing them to self-serve versus you
know a weekly update you know is is also
excellent and and certainly helpful.
So you know I I do agree in terms and and
again something that you know they have
access to internal dashboards now.
And that's probably a place also Jeremy,
we can kind of show you and you can poke
Yeah.
around and you can see how we're we're
displaying the data internally and and
start to think through kind of how this
could could function more efficiently and
you know be more you know digestible for
for the audience,
even the the internal stakeholders.
OK, yeah, I'd love to see it.
Cool. Any other and again,
so I'll I'll I'll share some examples.
Mhm.
Jeremy, Andy,
could you help get Jeremy set up with
with community access?
Yep, I can definitely do that.
Cool. Thank you. Hassan,
would would you like it as well?
Yes, please.
Cool. So we can do that. And then, Yep,
go ahead.
Already.
Yeah, and then.
You know, just, you know,
give me a little time to dig in.
Yeah, of course.
I'm sure I'll have a lot of questions and
then we can schedule a yeah, yeah.
Yeah,
there's there's a lot to wrap your head
around. I actually,
I I pull up this report just to give you
a sense of like this is one of our
campaigns.
It just has a ton of stuff going on,
right. So it's it's emails, it's surveys,
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
it's discussions with comments, right.
It's analysis. So again,
it's we we've kind of.
Put these together over time to in some
cases they're they're very large because
this client like loves this report.
So again,
but it's it's doesn't mean we'd have to
execute this for everyone.
But I'm I'm curious how how close to the
pin we can get with with some of the way
we we've been doing it.
Or again to your point,
just do what we're doing more efficiently
and add more value.
Right. Yeah. So, right.
So I would say next steps,
In a more automated way.
share this information, get us access,
you know, give me some time to review,
digest, understand.
If little questions come up in the
meantime, I'll just ping you.
But then let's plan on circling back in
Cool. Yeah, please.
maybe something like 2 weeks and at that.
At that point we'll try to have,
I'll try to have a very high level road
map for what you know,
state phases would look like and then we
can, you know, adjust the line,
ask questions, add,
remove whatever and go from there.
That that sounds excellent.
OK.
Yeah.
Any other questions or comments or
thoughts from everyone before before we
wrap?
Awesome.
Thanks again for for your help guys.
Nope, I'm good.
We're really looking forward to this.
Yeah.
Yeah, looking forward to it.
Looks like a a lot of value to be added.
A very complex one I think which will and
I feel like we can set a new standard for
Norstella with some of this complexity.
I I feel like we've got to be on the far
end of the spectrum in terms of reporting
output and all the configurations.
So maybe we can help some other companies
as well with what we learned.
Cool.
Alright, see y'all.
All right, thanks guys. Talk to you soon.
Cheers.
Thank you.
See you guys. Thanks. Bye, bye.
Thanks everyone.